there's an attraction that has come
since Iraq to many people on the right
and left of a sort of isolationism and I
at any rate still certainly don't share
that I don't think it's possible or
desirable for a country like America or
Britain to Simply have a domestic policy
and not have a foreign policy as well I
don't think it's desirable to believe
there's many people do particularly on
the right in America now that we have no
right to feel ourselves in any way able
to act in the world I don't accept that
as being the case I think that the cause
of internationalism the left right
internationalism of the kind that I
include in others represented has taken
a serious battering of late but I think
that there is also a battering for being
an isolationist as well I think there is
a battering for those people who believe
that you can effectively let the world
govern itself or police itself or let
the UN or other International bodies be
the only Arbiters I think that view also
takes a beating